bonjour à tous
je vais vous parler du travail
collaboratif et de l'aide à
visualisation mais avant je vais vous
raconter une petite histoire il s'agit
de l'histoire du peuple comorien on s'en
souvient tous de leur performance de ce
peuple valeureux lors de la canne 2022
ils ont vraiment été radieux bravo à eux
et c'est la conte mais ce dont il s'agit
aujourd'hui est de la diaspora
comorienne ce peuple valeureux et fort
qui finance la l'économie comorienne à
hauteur de 25% entre 20 jusqu'à 25%. en
fonction de l'année et pourtant ces
investissements qui sont quand même
massives 20% jusqu'à 25% quand même
c'est vraiment énorme pour un pays
c'est vraiment énorme ces
investissements ne sont pas bien
orientés dans le sens où cette diaspora
n'a pas la même mise dans leurs effets
ça donne entre eux ou non des business
dans l'immobilier d'autres dans le
commerce l'élevage dans la pêche la
l'agriculture de manière globale et bien
à notre domaine et malheureusement il se
plaignait tout sur des semaines
difficultés on n'arrive pas à gérer nos
équipes on a du mal à collaborer avec
nos équipes on arrive pas à y voir clair
par rapport à la facturation par rapport
aux encaissements par rapport à ce qui
se passe au magasin par rapport à ce qui
se passe dans nos bureaux finalement ils
sont éparpillés dans le monde l'Amérique
en Asie en Europe mais ils ont du mal à
coordonner leurs investissements au pays
au Comores en l'occurrence parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à y voir plus clair par
rapport à leur manière de collaborer
avec les équipes distantes c'est un
problème qui a gangrené les
investissements de de cette population
là pendant bien des années mais en 2018
quelque chose a changé un groupe de
jeûne comorien
issu de cette même diaspora ce sont
lancés un défi qui est de faire en sorte
de casser les codes de casser ce
problème et de trouver des solutions
concrètes
pour lancer des business à distance et
les développer et veiller également à ce
que d'autres puissent suivre en
proposant un modèle économique qui est
viable et comment ils ont fait
ils ont fait appel au travail
collaboratif d'une part mais également
de la visualisation pour une meilleure
visibilité
et prendre de bonnes décisions
intelligentes en occurrence il s'agit de
comorien
vous en avez tous entendu parler et
maman surtout ces jeunes comorien des
parties se trouvent comme roalding est
un groupe de jeunes au-delà de ce défi
que sur le lancés le défi qui est de
casser le code de proposer des solutions
concrètes pour rendre pour un business
model beaucoup plus rentable une manière
de faire beaucoup plus économique et
beaucoup plus durable au-delà de cela
mais ils ont également cassé aussi autre
chose
parce qu'ils ont proposé une nouvelle
solution à la communauté comorienne de
la diaspora de partir se trouve pour non
seulement gérer le business mais
également pouvoir agir aux Comores comme
si ils y étaient comment ils ont lancé
comment en ligne en l'occurrence la
première Marketplace e-commerce
en 2018 en permettant à tous les
Comoriens de porte qui se trouvent de
pouvoir acheter en ligne et en même
temps récupérer les marchandises
localement parce que le catalogue il est
d'une peur en ligne mais les stocks ils
sont disponibles dans les trois îles
donc
la diaspora achète en ligne de parts qui
se trouve leur famille récupère les
marchandises en local que je sois
alimentaire ou matériaux de construction
ou recharge de télécommunication vu
qu'il travaille en collaboration avec
les parts avec les opérateurs locales
mais tout cela pour dire que
ce groupe de jeunes ils ont d'une part
montrer une nouvelle façon de faire dans
l'aspect travail organisation et gestion
d'équipe
mais d'autre part également ils ont
lancé un business model qui était
inexistant jusque là pour permettre à
tous les Comoriens de parties se
trouvent de pouvoir agir au Comores
comme s'ils y étiez moi je m'appelle
nafat Sandy je suis le SIO et
cofondateur de cette start-up comme
rallye
un groupe de jeunes dynamique
issu de la diaspora qui ont été témoin
de tous les difficultés
dont la diaspora dont les Comoriens de
partout se trouvent vivaient
écoutez beaucoup de témoignages
beaucoup de problèmes mais finalement
nous avons décidé de tout casser et de
réinventer et de proposer une nouvelle
façon de faire une nouvelle façon qui
consiste à utiliser l'intelligence
collective
pour construire quelque chose de
meilleur et quelque chose de durable et
permettre surtout au plus jeune il y a
d'autres personnes de voir oui ça peut
marcher
on peut être aux États-Unis au Canada en
Inde et en Chine et lance un business
le développé en utilisant
le travail collaboratif en utilisant les
outils très performants qui sont
disponibles actuellement
mais concrètement qu'est-ce que ça fait
qu'est-ce qu'on gagne en vrai comment le
travail collaboratif a réussi
à régler ou à casser ses difficultés
que nous progesseurs ont vécu alors le
travail collaboratif propose un meilleur
gain de temps
pourquoi parce que la première des
choses consiste à centraliser
l'information dans un seul plateforme
d'un seul endroit et faire en sorte à
cette information là soit accessible à
tout le monde
tous les collaborateurs de partout se
trouvent peu importe le pays et
l'endroit du temps qu'il dispose
internet ils peuvent accéder à
l'information et dès l'instant que tout
le monde à l'information on réagi donc
ça provoque une meilleure réactivité
vis-à-vis de l'équipe chose qui n'était
pas le cas avant jusqu'à avant c'était
obscur c'était opaque on savait même pas
ce qui se passait à l'intérieur de la
boîte on voyait pas du tout mais avec
ces outils là avec cette manière de
proposer
des centraliser l'information sont un
seul endroit d'une part qui va engendrer
une meilleure productivité de la part de
toute l'équipe de la mesure où les gens
réagissent vite parce que tout le monde
a l'information il y a une flexibilité
qui s'installe parce que tout le monde a
l'information et cela engendre également
une meilleure collaboration parce que du
fait que tout le monde a l'information
qui cherche
il y a une discussion qui s'installe
entre toutes les équipes et cette
discussion là crée l'intelligence
collective et vous savez à quel point
l'intelligence collectif est puissant
pour développer toute forme de
structures
et cela dans l'ensemble il provoque
également une productivité assez énorme
j'en sais quelque chose parce que depuis
2018 et comme on va aller nos équipes
sont disponibles dans les trois îles des
îles Comores nous avons également des
équipes à Madagascar mais également en
France et tout ce travail dans une
synergie
et ça se passe tellement bien sûr il y a
des piratés ce qui est normal
mais on a tellement gagné un
productivité qu'aujourd'hui nous
connaissons une croissance assez
importante
qui fait que nous sommes toujours là on
a 4 ans d'existence et l'entreprise à
chaque année la croissance il est encore
plus énorme que l'année précédente et ça
c'est grâce à l'intelligence collective
que nous avons mise en place c'est grâce
au travail collaboratif que nous avons
mis en place qui nous a permis de gagner
un productivité et par conséquent
d'avoir de meilleurs résultats notre
part comme je dis depuis le début il y a
la data visualisation
nous sommes dans un monde où la
croissance des données il est
exponentielle toute étude confondu
sur la croissance des données montrer
dans un futur proche il sera très
difficile de pouvoir effectuer des
calculs classiques pour pouvoir
comprendre les données d'une entreprise
et donc récupérer de l'information ou de
la connaissance dans ces données là
il sera très difficile d'utiliser les
outils classiques pour cela
d'autres études montrent
que la meilleure façon de prendre la
meilleure façon d'avoir la connaissance
contenue dans les données de
l'entreprise et de les projeter sur un
visuel qui sera accessible à tous les
experts métiers c'est à dire
grâce à la dette à visualisation
il ne sera plus nécessaire que tu sois
une dotationiste ou bien une expérience
statistique ou que tu sois et
mathématicine pour comprendre
l'historique des données c'est à dire
comprendre pouvoir raconter le de ta
story toile il sera pas du tout
nécessaire il faudra tout simplement
projeter ces données là sur un visuel
logique et les proposer aux commerciaux
les proposer aux financiers au comptable
de sorte à ce que toute expert métier
puisse comprendre facilement et lire le
contenu se donner là et prendre des
décisions intelligentes
c'est c'est que comme Aurélie il a fait
il a compris que dans ce monde où il a
donné croit de plus en plus et de
manière exponentielle chaque année la
seule unique façon donc tirer les
connaissances de ces données là et
d'utiliser les technologies du moment
d'utiliser
pour comprendre
pour raconter l'histoire des données
pour raconter ce qui se passe pour
permettre de proposer une meilleure
expérience client pour permettre à
l'équipe aux équipes
de savoir où est-ce qu'ils en sont
aujourd'hui est devenu incontournable
pour la rentabilité de l'entreprise
selon l'institut statista dans les
années à venir la croissance de l'État
se valorisera autour de plusieurs
centaines et aujourd'hui tout le monde
n'est pas le thé scientiste tout le
monde n'est pas satisfiant tout le monde
est même mathématicien ce qui veut dire
qu'il faudra que les entreprises
trouvent des moyens plus simples de
faire parler les données de récupérer
l'information la connaissance qui est
dans les données et de les envoyer aux
experts métiers et comment à travers
d'une part la détermination et de trop
part la data storytonienne
tout simplement permettre de récupérer
l'information c'est à dire de projeter
les données sur des visuels et la
déteste storytolène permettra aux
experts métiers de raconter une histoire
à la traversée de l'histoire simple
facile et compréhensible à toute
personne qui comprend à peu près de quoi
il s'agit les métiers cet aspect là a
une grande valeur à une grande valeur
d'un entrepreneuriat d'aujourd'hui nous
comme on dit
ça a été un gros coup de pouce un gros
coup de pouce parce que ça nous a permis
d'une part de gagner du temps dans la
mesure où nous avons développé
des dashboard à travers simples des
comment dire
nous avons développé dashboard simple
dans lesquels on a réussi à connecter
les différents les différents ripos ou
des différentes bases de données qui
permet de récupérer l'information
et les projeter sur des dashboard qui
permet aux équipes commerciales
aux équipes qui font du marketing à ceux
qui font de la communication de pouvoir
lire l'information et récupérer la
connaissance
côté client pour une meilleure
expérience client et récupérer la
connaissance sur les capillaires
business
pour pour une meilleure analyse
financier de la société mais également
récupérer toute forme de CAPI pour
présenter de meilleurs indicateurs de
performance et aider la société à
s'améliorer et ces caps et ses
capillaires c'est-à-dire les indicateurs
de performance et qui ont été qui ont
été lu les récupérer c'est connaissance
qu'ont été récupérées à travers cette
visualisation ces données qui ont été
visualisées par les experts métiers
propose une meilleure rentabilité et
aide à prendre des décisions
intelligentes
et là au-delà
de cette capacité à optimiser les
décisions à les prendre de manière
intelligente mais cette visualisation de
données
cette story qui a été racontée par
l'expert métier permet à l'entreprise de
gagner beaucoup de temps dans la mesure
où
il ne va pas engager plusieurs de pour
gérer les données et tout ça mais tout
simplement il les projette et une
musique les experts métiers les
rencontres l'histoire de ces données là
et prennent l'information la
connaissance demandée et fait développer
la société
à titre personnel
c'est d'expérience là ce que je vous dis
aujourd'hui à nous a permis nous comment
en ligne de gagner beaucoup de temps de
gagner beaucoup en productivité et de
prendre des décisions intelligentes
adaptée à notre marché et permettre
surtout à toutes les équipes de gagner
beaucoup en productivité je vous
encourage pour le développement de votre
business d'adopter massivement le
travail collaboratif qui va vraiment
vous sauver la vie et vous permet de
gagner beaucoup de temps et toujours
opter pour la vue de nouveaux données
les automatisons pour gagner toujours du
temps et prendre des ions intelligentes
merci beaucoup